the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so this is a really really really really
stunning fact in a sense about we talked
about lots of forms of inequality and
unfairness in the world but here's a
fact that's really quite quite quite
striking the fact that you start from
the basic just the fact it's it's the
fact that if you look at the ratio of
men and women in the population most
countries in the world have many more
women than men this is mostly because
women are just better designed when men
get to the age of about sixty various
things have bad things happen to them in
particular their arteries seem to harden
and big it they get lots of them die
from various cardiovascular diseases so
as a result most countries have many
more women than men I mean so the ratios
add up there Europe has 1.05 sub-saharan
Africa as 1.02
most of like most of Latin America is
also above all of Latin America is above
one the u.s. is above one and while it
doesn't look like a lot you know four
percent we're talking a four percent of
you know
three billion so that's a fair number of
extra women we're talking about the
world has many more women than men
overall but the one place where that's
not true is in this belt which goes from
basically North Africa to Korea that's
that one belt in the world pretty much
all the way you can draw a belt starting
somewhere in in Morocco and keep going
east the border that latitude and that
belt has been gone a bit north into
China you'll find that that's where
there are about four percent or less
women than men so less and that's I
think that the numbers these numbers you
are sort of I think actually I'll show
you these numbers are not necessary the
worse numbers you're going to see so
I'll show you some more striking numbers
in a minute but I mean just the fact
that there's 6% less women than men is
striking given that that's not the
biological that doesn't look like the
biological model and the way so I might
assign who was a Nobel Prize winner at
Harvard did this calculation basically
very simple calculation he said look you
know sub-saharan Africa is the poorest
part of the world that's so if there is
some you know maybe institutional reason
why women die so there might be reasons
why women die which have to do with
poverty what's an example for reason
which which would hurt women more than
men why reason why poverty would hurt
women more than men childbirth the
obvious one is child yeah
so so everything to do with childbirth
is a reason why you might think that in
poor countries women will women will
have a disadvantage now you take that
disadvantage you do see evidence of the
disadvantage
sub-saharan Africa has less women than
Europe so you do see an example of or
decide that disadvantage it's about two
percentage points or three percentage
points less women then then then Europe
but that's if you think of sub-saharan
Africa as the part of the world which is
the highest maternal Malte mortality
rates is that part of the world which is
the highest fertility rates both to your
point and your point it has the if you
take the part of the world where women
are most like to die in childbirth and
the place where women have most children
both of those are highest in sub-saharan
Africa so you could think of this as
being a reasonable approximation of the
worst case scenario so take the worst
case scenario and then go to China so
that's the exercise let's take the worst
case scenario now go to China and ask if
we applied which the sub-saharan African
ratio to the Chinese population how many
more women would have had the answers
they would have had 44 million more
women so 44 million more women are
missing and that then you keep doing
that they're the same order of magnitude
in India and then smaller countries so
smaller numbers but it all adds up to
about 100 million so you get about 100
million missing women in the world by
doing this simple exercise and that sort
of
prima facie evidence as we'll see you
have to think harder about exactly what
this evidence means but it's prime my
face the evidence of something very
bizarre happening when you know whether
this is exactly will see or what's going
on here but there's something very
troubling about this fact because it
seems like somehow populations are
managing to get rid of women quote uncle
losing women through mechanisms which
are not the normal biological mechanisms
so that's the that's the missing so
before I come to that there's just some
questions you might hypothesis you might
have one is is is like development the
answer maybe it's just that you know
people are somehow to true there's some
some reason why just being
underdeveloped for reasons we don't
understand translates into less women we
do maybe we have a theory that maybe
it's the case that people are more
traditional something now what makes
this fact much more worrying is the
development is not making this fact go
away
that's sort of a at least within within
modern history we don't know what what
what happened 100 years ago but right
now development is not making this fact
go away if you look at the sex ratio in
India it's not changing it's in fact
pretty much steady I'll show you numbers
in a bit if you should look at the sexes
in China it's falling it's less and less
women every year in China and if you
look at the richest parts of China
the poorest part to your question you
see a negative correlation the richest
parts of China are the ones which have
the least women yeah
perfectly it's a good question I mean
it's how I think that's what people do
when they say the infant mortality rate
is too high or something and I think
that that's a I mean that's that's also
a concern it's not that there are other
concerns because of this that's sort of
what a lot of lot of like a lot of
people who say that you know you
shouldn't just look at GDP to measure
welfare emphasize the infant mortality
rates the infant mortality rates is
exactly the question you're asking kind
of missing boys and girls and you do see
that that numbers very high in
sub-saharan Africa sub-saharan Africa
has the highest infant mortality rate in
the world by far China has now infant
mortality rates which are approaching
that in the u.s. so it's not so infant
mortality rate by itself is not the
right by now it's not a huge problem in
China China is down to the range where
you know it's very very close to the US
I think here's the environment of like
twenty five out of a thousand thousand
live births you ss-18 or you know 14 or
something it's it's really in the range
where where sub-saharan Africa Sierra
Leone has 140 so even if you just take
thee so if you want to see where infant
mortality is a problem that's not where
missing women is a problem this is
different problems it's not to say
you're not right that's another problem
but it's it's a different one so this is
sort of just just to show you that fact
if you look at which are the countries
which have this is the trend in the in
so what I showed you so far was the
levels how many women per men this is in
2005 what's happened what's the future
futures much more scary than the press
the present is what hundred so if you
like hundred there was like 95 girls 400
boys so that's about 105 boys per 100
girls right that's the current the
future you look at look at a number for
eastern Asia that numbers hundred and
twenty boys four hundred dollars so
that's like it's a completely different
order of magnitude right it's like you
didn't think of the future these are the
kids who are being born under five so at
some point if this is what stays steady
we're going to see numbers like more
like hundred and twenty then 105 right
now the there were 105 boys 200 girls in
China and that numbers going to go up to
closer to 120 if this Co has this cohort
ages so that's so that's not that's just
backing up the first claim I made which
is not it's not getting better if you
look at the number for india
201-409-1811
interestingly Afghanistan and Nepal
which are relatively poor country vision
not getting rich very rich very fast
actually you don't see much of a change
there about where they were so there
their ratio is about in the under five
is about what they are in the adult
population so that suggests that they
are getting worse is a Ricci countries
are getting richer are getting worse
yeah that's absolutely true so 120 won't
go to 120 120 is gone to 115 that's
about the difference so hundred is going
to 115 or 14 but 114 is a lot better
than hundred worse than 106 so this
numbers just all the trends are bad
let's sort of just just just to
understand this is a big problem it's
not one that's getting solved by on its
own as far as I can tell
so here's another way to look at it so
this is India and in China give yourself
a few minutes to look at this so the the
darkest areas are the worst areas
does anybody know which are the richest
richer areas of China
yeah it's pretty much exactly the same
you know hey Shanghai is that gray area
right there which is actually doing
surprisingly well with the rest of China
which is the really poor areas of China
are those very light areas in the East
in the West
that's the Gobi Desert the Taklamakan
desert the Shing Kyung all the areas
where you know with large Muslim
populations are in the East these are
the poorest parts of China and they are
the ones which are doing by far the best
the areas that are doing really badly at
the most prosperous you know the dark
areas in the southeast that's that's
like Guangdong and Guangzhou and all
these really like fast-growing wealthy
provinces of China
that's the southeast so that's that's a
map that suggests lot of this I think
has something to do with people's active
choices oh now we'll come back to that
in a little bit but but you this pattern
is you know you think of as the China
gets even richer if this is the trend
then it's a worrying trend let's say now
look at India again do you know what
what those relatively pale areas are the
South India which is relatively
prosperous and well-educated and East
India which is the poorest and the most
backward part of India so if you take
you as you go west and north you're
going to some of the richer richest
richest parts of a richest state in
India large state in India is
Maharashtra which is the kind of the
Striped state let's see on the west
coast the first state that's not you go
from the south on the west coast the one
the first striped one that's Maharashtra
that's that's the richest but the second
richest large state is Delhi Punjab and
Punjab is that the piece of black that's
right in the north so that there are
that's literally the second richest and
still recently the richest state in
India is that area or in black so again
same pattern rich states have worse
outcomes not better outcomes there's no
evidence of of
of a positive correlation between income
and and the gender ratio
maybe so Punjab has but that that's
actually what that is it's really two
states there is Punjab and Haryana they
used to be both apart of Punjab now they
were split into two states for some
years one of the one of those states is
seek majority seek is a particular other
religion the others Hindu majority
there's no difference actually Haryana
slightly worse than Punjab Delhi City is
one of the worst places actually in
India so that's one of the absolutely
richest places
so basically no evidence of a positive
correlation between income and the
gender ratio gender ratio if everything
gets worse as you get richer for reasons
that may very well be close to what you
suggested but it's clear that you get
this rather dismal pattern here's some
something else another fact about sort
of China and it's sort of a very long
term view of China so if you look at
that this starts in 1920 and you can see
that basically so the 1920s the excess
say sex ratio which is in the five year
in the five year birth cohort so people
who are born in that year what's the
what's the fraction of boys versus girls
so it used to be about you know 7% more
boys than girls then it went up to about
sixteen percent during the years when
there's a lot of political instability
so if you think of that those years as
Japanese invasion before that and after
that in a sense China is in civil war
there's a big you know what are called
the warlords are fighting each other
through China so during wars you see
this ratio going way up then it comes
down down down
now till about 1976 or something
now writer of 1976 something else
happens China Institute was called the
one-child policy one-child policy is one
where at least in the richer areas where
it was is only person and forced
families were allowed to have only one
child at most then that policy gets
implemented in the mid-70s and you see
what happened since but striking is that
it doesn't just go up and stay up it
keeps going up so there's something else
going on on top of the fact that the
one-child policy gets instituted in fact
that over time the one-child policy has
been relaxed families which have had you
know and this reflects some of the
tastes of the population clearly
families which had one daughter were in
some areas were allowed to have a son or
have a second child more more recently
so there's some attempt to relax the
policy in exactly the direction that
suggests that there is a preference for
boys but with all that the trend has
been palpable
yeah
there's a relaxation actually a bunch of
the relaxer surgeons have one you see
that flattening in about 1982 that's the
first relaxation so you do see a
flattening but trend is so good this
beginner a stopping good so amazing that
families have a stopping rule which says
we will stop when we have the first boy
okay this is the stopping rule this is
plausible stopping rule
my mother had has three brothers it's
one brother and three sisters the
brothers a youngest so that's that's not
an implausible stress stopping rule my
mother's only brother has three
daughters and one son the son is the
youngest so it's not it's not an
implausible sign stopping rule however
imagine we had this stopping rule but in
any birth the probability of boy and
girl would equal what would be the
population sex ratio
which ones
if you keep having children
and he starts
tell me
there might be
they worked
that here will be more feminist
so you think it will be more the boiler
workers I think we're going to stop
sitting back Emily just has a boy you're
a girl then you try again the new boys
that I know you won't tell me the one
there's still more boys than girls get
up get the boy to stop yourself you
wouldn't come back to that
yeah just didn't expect yeah one boy
you're exactly right the answer is it
doesn't change anything
and it's very simple to see the reason
why it doesn't change anything is very
simple which is that every birth has a
50% chance of having a boy so just take
the number of but forget about families
there's a certain number of but let's
say 50 million but 25 million of those
births will be bought boy than 25
million of those BOTS would be girls
doesn't matter which family it happens
every birth is a separate independent
event and has 50% chance of being a boy
so it they have paradoxical as this
sound stopping rules don't change the
sex ratio they change the distribution
now here's what might be going on which
is more complicated directly it doesn't
matter
every every birth is an independent
event with a 50% chance of being a boy
so take the number of births multiplied
by 50% you whether the number of so it
makes no difference now let's think of
one more step in their argument which
families would a lot of girls going on
grow up in how many how many children
will would their more children or less
children but girls grow up on average in
a family with more children less
children more children so if you think
that families that have more children
have less resources then you have a
stopping rule then girls will be growing
up in families with more children and
therefore less resources and therefore
girls will be a stopping rule can have
an effect on on child outcomes because
it goes it girls it leads to girls being
all living in large families and boys
all living in small families so boys get
all the attention the parental resources
girls you know this
even girls you know and one boy in the
in the girl families and therefore the
girls end up with getting less resources
so that's one possible reason why you
might get this outcome is that it has
something to do with the stopping rule
but not directly just to do with the
stopping rule then generates an
allocation of girls across families you
imagine a family in a rich area where
you know everything's expensive let's
say even if it was a little bit more
relaxed they still limit themselves to
say okay we're gonna have a maximum two
kids so let's say yeah like me the first
kid and they have it's a girl but then
they say you know the probability of
having a girl for the next one maybe
it's not really 50% because they say
well unless we can have this game yeah
so it's know what you're saying is
completely right that the only way you
get away from 50/50 is by deliberately
or at least doing something to the girl
that makes a not live that's the only
way you get there if she if you have if
the girls who are born live then you
know you can't get away from this it's
it doesn't matter what your stopping
rule is even if the government makes
complicated policies the policies don't
change that you know every birth is
either a boy or a dog okay
so here's the last fact I wanted you to
see which is that if you look at the sex
ratios in India they're getting worse
they got worse for a while now they have
stay stabilized at a lower number so in
1900 there were nine seventy two girls
or boys or men for women women for men
well there's 933 so that's just the
trend is in India you don't see a trend
after 1971 or 1981 but it's it's it's
the trend historical trend is is very
negative so that that brings us to the
sort of the question before we get to
policy in a sense we need to know what's
going on what's going on the two
possible answers one is kind of
tradition and there is economics so so
one is like people are actually there's
a set of traditions which make bad
things happen but people are not willing
them to happen and the other is that
people are actually making choices to
make these things happen so when when
the char so what we're going to spend
some time doing is trying to distinguish
between these two views views is it
tradition is it economics so you could
imagine just traditionally there's some
theory which says that girls need less
food and it's false but you you believe
it and you don't actually actively do
anything to make them die you just
believe you have wrong beliefs you think
girls need less food because you know
adult women are smaller than adult men
and so you feed your girls less this is
not an attempt to kill them it's just a
tradition tradition but then that could
feed back and have a consequence right
then you could see problem is how do you
test this
yep actually look like fertility rates
and so yeah I don't like if the number
of people that are born in section ball
fifty-fifty but then an ugly like within
five years you see a bigger difference
so main support that sound
but even if in terms of birth rate if
there's a difference than sure than us
so part of it is one answer to this
question is if these guys are not
getting born and then obviously
something else is going on now mostly
till about five years ago or not five
fifteen years ago you don't see a big
trend in birthrate the trend now you
actually see a trend in birth rates as
well reported births are getting there
more and more reported boys relative to
girls but about fifteen years ago you
don't see that what you did see was more
different mortality rates for boys and
girls so imagine that you wanted to test
this view well the problem is how do you
test it you don't actually observe who
eats what in a family so it's hard to
imagine you going and figuring out or if
they're not feeding their daughter and
they're fitting their son and it's just
too difficult to do because you know
everybody eats out of the same cooked
food and so it's going to be very hard
to find so somebody had a very good idea
of how to how to do it which is to look
at specialized adult goods like
cigarettes you know your daughter
five-year-old daughter doesn't smoke a
cigarette
nor does your 5d five year old son so
when when a son is born if there's an
effect on how much smoking you do it has
nothing to do with nothing to do with
the children you know children smoking
so children are not going to be a direct
source of demand so then you can why is
that good because then you can look at
what happens to smoking
when the family gets a boy or a girl and
which one you if girls are fed less what
would you expect
right or smoking smoking goes down by
less
so the basic observation you should see
is when a child is born adult income
goes down right because adults have less
money money to spend on themselves
because they will feel feed the child
but if they feed the boil less than the
girl got less than the boy and you see
that they will they will they will when
a boy is born they will really cut back
on cigarettes but when a girl is 1
they'll cut back less because they are
feeding the girl legs so we have pretty
precise measurement of demand for adult
goods so we can use that we don't know
who who smokes but we know the kids are
not doing the smoking so therefore we
can by observing what happens to a
family when of child is born we can back
out whether or not there is a difference
in in the way you feed boys or girls is
that clear why that's better than trying
to measure it's very hard to measure who
eats what but clear the kids don't eat
they don't drinks you don't smoke
cigarettes and they don't drink alcohol
so if we look at alcohol and cigarettes
and a few other things that are
essentially adult Goods we should be
able to back out what's happening when
the child is born
that is it clear what the so somebody
did that I'll show you the data for
India it
so take beverages beverages is doesn't
include milk
so if soda and tea and all those things
and this is just basically what this
table is horrible but this paper was
published in a obscure journal many
years ago and the only way I could do is
just this is a scan of that there's
nothing else I could find there's no
electronic version etc so but it's what
you're looking for is the effect of a
boy versus a girl so males number of
males between 0 & 4 versus number of
females between 0 & 4 and the effect of
that on the consumption of beverages the
answer is it has no effect that what's
in the bracket is the T statistic T
statistics is 0 but if anything yeah I
mean there's just both know what the
numbers are zero and that's basically
what you find you find no effect of yeah
you see you see what you'd expect which
is that for example when a child is born
you are just poor so you buy less rice
less wheat but there's no no difference
between girls and boys boys and girls
are the same effect if anything on both
so you just find there's no evidence
that basically there's no evidence that
when a child is born families cut boy
child is born families cut back more
than when a girl child is born there's
this you don't we don't find any
evidence and this has been looked in
many countries so another tradition
story is the following
imagine that tradition is you know when
the child gets sick do I take it to the
hospital
and with a boy the tradition is I always
take it the hospital with it with a girl
I just let her you know give us some
water and you know generally you know
make you know sing songs to her but I
don't take it to the hospital something
like that you know do we see any
evidence of this so this is hard to
study because you know we don't actually
observe that many episodes of
life-threatening diseases but there's a
nice there's a nice fact that a lien
arose identified which is the following
she looked at Ariel so over time
different air different parts of India
have droughts at different points of
time so some some people some areas have
droughts in in 2006 some have droughts
in 2004 some have droughts in 1996 so a
drought is a time of economic stress so
drought is when what's a draught why is
it economic stress
yeah basically you can't grow anything
is too dry so so when the rains fail
crops failed families have no money how
are they dealing with this particular
emergency and yeah and there she finds
some evidence that relative to non
drought years in drought years
girls die more so that suggests that
emergencies might be a part of the story
that in emergencies girls are not
treated as well so I give in one example
which is not taking her to the hospital
the other one might be when I don't have
money I don't buy food for her so some
some tradition of that kind might
explain it problem is the droughts are
not frequent enough and you remember the
trends the trends are all bad right they
all getting worse the India and China
are getting richer the dependence on
agriculture and general these kinds of
extreme events is just going down people
are just you know droughts don't matter
as much as in India now then when it 20
30 years ago agriculture was 50% of GDP
now it's 25 percent of GDP so basically
droughts matter less to people and since
jobs matter less to people you would
imagine the trend being favourable
rather than against think of China most
people are now in industry they're not
there they're also richer and as you get
Richard you would imagine that
emergencies are less serious because you
know you always have some money you know
no longer at the margin of starvation so
problem with the story is that it's just
inconsistent with the fact that things
are getting worse over time you would
think that under this story things will
be getting better because it's an
emergency story and as countries get
richer and less exposed to risk there
would be you'd see less and less of this
rather than more and more of this so
that's why this can't be the whole
explanation it could be a piece of it so
here's a
so going back to our distinction between
the kind of the tradition based stories
and the more economic stories here's a
is an economic fact which is striking so
if you like this so in other words what
I mean by an economic story is that
tradition based stories say that you
know there's some rule people use fixed
rule which there's not they're not
decided on this rule this is given to
them and that rule somehow under some
circumstances has bad outcome for girls
so in a when the girl is sick you don't
take her to the hospital that's a rule
this is something we're now asking a
question when the economic incentives to
treat girls better changes do you treat
them better that suggests that you not
don't have a fixed rule you're you're
actually behaving in a kind of rational
way quote-unquote rational way you are
you're actually planning to behave bad
things happen to girls so do you see
what the distinction is between
traditional tradition based stories and
economic stories economic stories are
ones which essentially say that you know
we are making active choices which have
consequences for girls rather than this
is a rule we use and sometimes bad
things happen because we use a
particular rule here so here this is a
nice example so in China after 1979
agriculture is liberalized meaning
people are allowed to keep the money
from growing their crops this is the
start of China's economic miracle it's
it's called the family responsibility
system and it's sort of when everything
in China starts T is one crop where
women have a compare comparative
advantage and even absolute advantage
which T is something that has to be
picked very patiently small leaf the
most valuable leaves in tea are the
smallest ones
so here to pick that small leaves you
have to pick them without bruising them
the leave is Bruce the price goes down
so you know the best leave teas like
Chinese teas sell for you know six
hundred dollars a kilogram so something
of the order of magnitude of you know
it's pretty expensive so if you actually
have the best teas and you bruise a leaf
that costs money so you better have
someone you picks with very delicate
fingers turns out at least whether it's
true or not I don't know but it's
believed in China that women are better
for picking expensive tea leaves maybe
they are maybe this is a story that men
made up to make them do it but whatever
whatever the explanation this is this is
a this is the belief so given that
belief
what matters is what people believe here
right because that's you would imagine
that another crop which is the opposite
is fruits fruits need someone to climb a
tree and pick them and again in China
the belief is that where men are better
at climbing trees maybe again forms but
so men are better men are bidding better
at picking fruits women are better
picking tea let's starting that at least
that's what people believe let's start
from them now
suppose parents respond to economic
incentives then what would you expect
happens when the price of tea goes up
what what do you think will happen to
their daughter yeah
they treat their daughter better they're
going to feed her more or they're going
to you know take it to the hospital more
willingly etc so you'd expect that and
likewise even the price of fruits goes
up you'd expect men to be boys to be
treated better now
in fact both price of fruit and trees go
up and that's a that's a trend so it's
hard to use the trend to study this
because everything is going up all
both tea and fruits are going up so you
can't distinguish between these two but
one thing you can do is you can look at
areas which are suitable for tea areas
just suitable for fruits and the areas
were suitable for neither and now you
can say when tea prices go up
do we see a bigger change in the gender
ratio in the tea favour in the tea
suitable areas relative to the others or
you can ask when the price of of tea go
of fruits go up do you see a bigger
change in the gender ratio in the fruit
favorite areas than in the areas where
neither is favored so we're always
comparing areas where you know basically
wheat or rice grows with Thierry's and
fruit areas is that clear what we are
doing we're asking when the price of
fruits goes up do we see a different
trend in fruit growing areas relative to
wheat growing areas the clearer why
that's why that's a good way to look at
this question what are we worried or
worried about if we just said well the
price of tea is going up what's
happening to to girls
well the price is still going up but
that's going up over time if the girl is
the fraction of girls is going down
we'll get a negative association out of
that because they're two things
happening one is that it's just going
down for other reasons there are those
prices of tea is going up for up for
whatever economic reasons and I'm going
to correlate them or find a negative
correlation so that's not what you want
to do you want to look at areas which is
suitable for tea that's where the price
of tea should have an effect should not
have an effect where in areas which are
not suitable for tea so we're going to
compare the effect of an increase in
price of tea in girls suitable areas in
tea suitable areas versus non tea
suitable areas not compare trends this
is basically what is called doing a
difference in difference I'm going to
take high teat periods
i T price periods lo T price periods and
compared t suitable areas and non t
suitable areas you look more loss than I
would expect it's very easy idea so
somebody else want to say back what what
I'm trying to say
who's going to volunteer to improve on
that explanation
and we're apology
if this does actually have an effect
on how parents treat children
the girls treated better in places Worth
T of like the cash back or something
increases versus areas where T is not
the kind of increases there shouldn't be
changed right so we're going to compare
area years where T prices went up with
tears when T prices didn't go up and
compare them with in areas where T is a
plausible crop and areas where T cannot
be grown so the increase in T prices
should have no effect with T cannot be
grown it have a spurious effect maybe
but no real effect it should have an
effect where T can be wrong so we're
gonna compare tea tea tea possible areas
with other areas when tea prices go up
versus when it doesn't
that's exactly right another way to say
the same thing anybody else wants to add
add anything to that so let me show you
some some trends first so that's that's
the basic fact which we will do so
that's T prices suddenly in 79 you see
start T prices just skyrocketed
that's first fact P prices are going up
t productions going up second thing is
that if you look at T versus other crops
T prices a way of faster than other
crops so other crops are like grain
grain is going up but T is going up
faster oil is going up but T is going up
faster so T's the crops is going up
fastest among these these crops look at
this one here we're comparing fruits
with T and fruits are going up much
faster than fruits with other crops like
grain oil and and cotton and again
fruits are going up much faster so
basically what matters is not the
absolute price right it matters the
relative price matters because it's it's
some it's what makes you want to do more
T so T areas are benefiting relative to
those other areas so here's the basic so
this is a complicated graph so let's do
this slowly they try to understand what
what's in this graph so what in what in
this graph is areas where which grow a
lot of T this is the effect of this is
the coefficient or in a regression of so
this is the effect of
having more area devoted to tea in a
particular year so what this is saying
is that even before 1979 you see tea
prices are low in those years you see
some if you look at the fraction of melt
the fraction of ales bounces around but
it's a the effect the the fact that tea
is sown has essentially very close to
zero effect after 1979 the fact that tea
is sown has a much bigger effect so this
is the effect of how much land you put
into tea in a particular year so here by
year so in that year what's happening in
in 1983 how many boys versus girls were
born in high tea areas relative to load
the areas that's always the exercise so
think of one more one more percent of
land devoted to tea what is the effect
of that on the fractional of fraction of
boys born in 1983 that's what that says
so the main point to take away is that
in 90 you see a big drop after 1979 so
tea areas the fraction of boys born goes
down right when you think it should go
down which is when the price starts
going up so that that's what this is
saying before that the average is kind
of at point 0.15 the after that the
average is about 0.35 so the fraction of
boys goes down after this change this is
what happens to in the fruit areas the
opposite right after 79 fruit prices go
up also a lot and fruit favors boys
so the fraction of boys goes the ratio
used to be lower
it goes up afterwards yeah
yes so the average is significantly
different so it's not your right
that year by year it did not significant
but that's because it's a small sample
of people but if you take the average of
these these these periods the averages
are significantly different
I mean the economics inside I can't see
families consciously choosing to have
more girls for 1112 years still yeah
well yes and no you write that but on
the other hand it's also sent a signal
which reminds them oh well you know two
things one you might imagine that the
women might be more Pro girls plausibly
no and if you think that women income
share goes up in the family they have
more say so that's one possible
mechanism the second mechanism is just
that you know they maybe when the income
goes up when girls incomes go up they
just look at it well maybe my girl will
actually be you know after all the every
all the women are working these days why
not have another girl they'll be fine
they'll get they'll they'll have to find
a job as well I mean I can't tell what's
going on at that level but it's clear
that this result is significant it's
actually substantial okay final set of
thoughts suppose this goes on so know
what's going on how how are they losing
all these girls if it's an economic
mechanism we need to us
that's that says that there is incentive
to lose the girls how are they actually
doing it what's going on
unfortunately it's all not very nice
so two things are happening one is
basically the technology for pre-birth
detection of gender of the child has
improved a lot if you do amniocentesis
which is an expensive procedure you can
basically very high probability predict
the gender of the child the reason why
rich areas aren't doing the worst is
precisely because of that rich areas are
using this technology to figure out who
there it's an expensive technology so
you have to use it you spend money to
use it rich areas you see in like the
richer parts of India signs up with say
you would you rather spend basically a
hundred dollars now or hundred ten
thousand dollars later which is
basically the idea is that you have to
give dowry for your daughter to get her
married and that's your cost and so you
should really get rid of spend you know
whatever a hundred dollars now identify
her and then have a sexy look an
abortion rather than spend did you see
this signs up you know they're all
little illegal em new synthesis about
our eight years ago was made illegal in
India it's still completely prevent and
people and since people are willing to
try to have many babies they even
willing to do it if by using a much
weaker technology the scenography
sonography which is a technology that is
legal you can doesn't identify the
gender of the child all the time but
about twenty five percent of the time it
does and when it does then you can
immediately about the child
so they're using technologies to
identify this is why this is happening
more in richer areas because
technologies cost money and the poorest
areas are ones where the technology is
less least used because it's just
expensive so you see basically a very
very clear correlation between
where the technology arrives and the
fraction of boys being born so that's
one one thing that's going on second
thing that's going on almost surely is a
lot of post but I think murder is the
only word you could use I think
unfortunately there's a lot of I think
children being disposed off their
villages which are report to have
proudly report there's a news report I
think from like the Chinese News Agency
which says that we haven't had a boy
born in our village for the last five
years a girl born in my our village in
the last five years there was a news
news report of the village chief proudly
announcing that he had there was no girl
born in his village in the last five
years so I think there is a lot of just
direct deliberate action going on there
now one thing to think about is there
many things to think about here how do
you stop it well the government has
tried it tried to have technologies they
listen there's a bunch of programs
around now for example India has a
number of states where they have
programmed which basically promised
parents a certain amount of money if her
if your girl graduates from high school
quite a lot of money so that's one way
to go is give incentives based on girls
arrival various versions of that that
program are but it's not clear how well
that works because in some some ways
that's a still it's something that's
based on 20 years later and you don't
necessarily want people think that
people at that responsibility that's the
other thing you can think about is is
there any economic force that this sets
by itself it sets on which will set off
which will then make can really breathe
so one issue that arises is is what's
happening to the marriage market so what
do you think will happen to the marriage
market in China
yeah so you would see the emergence
dowdy should go down and bride-price
should go up now one reason this hasn't
happened already is that men who at
least in why doesn't happened already in
India especially is it men tend to marry
women who are younger than them if the
populations growing then there and
people marry women who are younger than
them then even if there are fewer girls
born the girls are from a different
cohort from a younger cohort so there
are the populations growing so there are
more girls around right so that's one
problem that this force might have
operate but only if population growth
stops so it's going to operate more in
China the population growth has stopped
then in India where the population
growth is still going on as long as its
population growth you're going to see
this possibility of just going down in
the cohort chain rather then so you
might imagine that the price of gold
would go up but it won't go up
if people marry much younger women
that's one issue second issue so in
China you do start so in China one of
the things that people are often puzzled
about is what's going on with the
savings rate the savings rate in China
is personal savings rate is historically
unprecedented people spend saved 30
percent of their incomes this is as
against compare the u.s. which used to
space a safe zero till recently and
after the crisis has gone up to seven
percent so personal savings rate in the
in China are massive
so one puzzle people have offered
worried of thinking mean thinking or is
what's going on with that it's a very
nice paper with just the following it
asks if I look at areas which have high
gender ratios
where women are really scarce are people
saving more in those areas
why would they save more why would you
save one if you're a parent of a boy
so in particularly asked if you're a
parent of a boy in China it's easy
because people have one child so either
a parent of a boy or a girl compared to
a boy in an area where the gender ratio
is particularly bad so very few girls
you turns out to save more why would
that be the case yeah you buy all your
son a bride so people are saving more so
basically they suggest that people are
now beginning to save more in order to
buy this child of a bride and the way
you buy it is you don't go and buy her
in a market but basically women have
become very picky about not marrying
into families which can't afford to give
their son a separate apartment to to
move into when when they get married
China has very poor mortgage markets so
you can't really take out the mortgage
to buy a house so what you basically the
only way you buy a house is you borrow
from your parents or your parents give
you a gift so parents now it's become a
status issue for parents to marry their
son and the way you marry your son is by
buying him an apartment when he gets
married so if you not don't have enough
wealth you can't buy an apartment and
then your son can't get married so this
seems to be sort of one of the fact that
that might actually really brihat China
because it seems like one thing that's
going on in China right now is this
massive increase in savings and I'm sure
that this this is not the problem within
this massive increase in savings is it a
completely it's a zero-sum game right
there are only so many girls so the fact
that I'm saving a lot for my son just
means my son can have a bride but not
anybody else
this it's not that the number of women
go up because I save so this is not
really solving the problem it's
squeezing parents because parents now I
have to so if I'm going to say $1 more
in order to buy my son a house so he can
get married then
somebody else is going to want to do the
same thing he's going to try to save
even more than me and buy a house for
his son so that competition is going to
is a very kind of a negative competition
everybody's getting hurt by that
competition so that should make parents
really rethink this strategy so I mean
that's the one one sign of hope I see is
this one which is a we use the market
forces seem to be kind of operating to
make this problem better that's true in
China less much less to it India because
India still populations growing so
there's still this memorize you know
adjustment okay so questions comments
last stop yeah
yeah you so you might see that well you
are seeing it yeah but maybe once it
gets clear that you know your daughter
gets to live in a wonderful apartment
etc and having a son is a huge pain
because you have to now find ways to pay
for his you know apartment you might
result preferring daughters so maybe we
will see that okay thank you
you